five thousand five hundred twenty four
plus zero well I'm adding zero I'm
adding nothing so still it was going to
be five thousand five hundred and twenty
four by what number can we multiply
eight thousand eight hundred ninety five
to get one well we're gonna have to
multiply it times its reciprocal so
we're going to multiply it times or we
could say its its multiplicative inverse
sometimes one way of thinking about it
and that's just going to be one over
eight thousand eight hundred and ninety
five you multiply eight thousand eight
hundred ninety five times one over eight
thousand one over eight thousand eight
hundred ninety five you are going to get
one fifteen fifty five times one well
anything times one is going to be that
anything so this is just going to say
one this is essentially saying one
fifteen fifty five so that's just going
to be fifteen fifty five 1555 one
thousand five hundred forty three plus
zero while we're adding nothing to it so
it's just going to be 1543 5804 plus
zero once again we're adding nothing to
its is just 5804 what number can we add
to 1893 to get to zero so we're gonna
have to essentially take 1893 away so
the only number that we can add that
would take away 1893 is negative 1893
this added to 1893 is equal to zero
anything times one is going to be that
anything so it's gonna be seven thousand
three hundred and sixty by what number
can we multiply 4850 to get one well
we've already done this this is just
going to be one over four thousand eight
hundred and fifty and we are we are done